At American colleges,
if you are a faculty member
and you want more pay or a promotion,
you must publish articles
in journals like these
since the journals supposedly have high standards…
some researchers were thrilled to get an email
from a journal that said:
I have now closely considered the revisions
of your manuscript dog park.”
[laughs] Dog park!!
They’re laughing because they’d just pulled off a hoax.
“...and will recommend
its publication in Gender, Place, and Culture.
[laughs]
they'd sent so-called research to
20 prominent journals in women and gender studies,
race studies, sexuality fat and queer studies.
For this journal of social work…
We rewrote
a section of Mein Kampf as intersectional feminism.
And this journal has accepted it.
Seven of their crazy papers got in.
And one that claims that dog humping incidents
can be taken as evidence of rape culture
– has been officially honored as “excellent scholarship”.
I'm thinking oh my god, we got a paper in
and it's probably the craziest thing we wrote
James Lindsay is a mathematician.
Peter Boghossian teaches philosophy..
Helen Pluckrose runs an academic magazine in London.
They didn’t really expect that the journal of
gender, place and culture would accept their paper,
in which they claimed to have “closely” examined
genitals of nearly 10,000 dogs
to learn about rape culture and queer performativity.
Did they just not read these things and accept them?
Oh no.
They read them very very carefully.
They read them in detail.
How could they believe you examined
10,000 dog genitals?
We have no idea, in fact in the ...
[Laughs]
the first draft of that paper we were like,
there is no way they're gonna believe that we did this.
We think studying topics
like gender race
and sexuality is worthwhile
and getting it right is extremely important.
They made this video to explain
why they tested the journals.
A culture has developed
in which only certain conclusions are allowed
-- like those that make whiteness
and masculinity problematic.
Basically
it’s not correct
that there is such a thing as biological sex.
Kind of a last straw happened.
There was this paper, well-funded by the
National Science Foundation that
studied feminist glaciology.
it said that glacier science is sexist
Because the majority of glaciological knowledge
that we have today stems from knowledge created
by men about men
within existing masculinist stories.
The paper’s remedy?
Feminist paintings of glaciers and
feminist art projects that,
I'm not kidding,
hooked up a phone line to a glacier so you could
call the glacier on the phone and listen to it.
So that was the last straw for me
These aren't your fields.
No. No.
No.
Which should have made it more difficult.
Much more difficult to fool the journals,
but --
Papers started getting in.
You ** got to be ** that this happened!
This shouldn't have been possible.
What appears beyond dispute is that making absurd
and horrible ideas sufficiently politically fashionable
can get them validated at the highest levels
of academic grievance studies.
We flattered what they wanted to hear
and then they told us that it was
an important contribution to feminist geography.
Maybe these are just mills that accept every paper.
No. One journal we hoaxed was Hypatia,
which is one of the two leading feminist journals.
It has about an 18 percent acceptance rate.
[Barking dogs]
The researchers didn’t get to finish their experiment
because the dog rape paper was so over-the-top,
a Wall Street Journal reporter noticed.
She exposed the hoax and ended the experiment
before all the journals had weighed in.
The 7 that accepted the fake papers did retract them.
But what upsets me most is what happened next.
No university said “hmm ...
... we’re not gonna use these journals.”
No editor publicly said,
“we have to raise our standards.”
Think about if you did this to civil engineers
with bridge-building.
They would've thanked us.
Right?
Because they're driving over the bridges
with their families.
So they don't want the bridges to collapse.
But the grievance study journal editors,
instead of admitting that they’d published nonsense,
criticized the hoaxers.
You've clearly engaged in flawed and
unethical research.
That was our whole point.
A dozen of Peter’s fellow professors wrote
an anonymous letter attacking him
and the school newspaper ran it with this cartoon
depicting peter as a clown.
You're part of a clown car of hoax writers engaging in
fraudulent, time-wasting, anti-intellectual activities.
Right. They just described their own discipline.
Do you dread walking to class?
Yes.
I've been spat on.
I've been physically threatened.
Portland State University, instead of applauding Peter
for exposing nonsense,
may fire him.
I called Portland State, asking for an interview,
but they declined.
How can a college criticize the hoaxers,
but revere ridiculous journals that publish nonsense?
When you live in these tight ecosystems,
this stuff makes total sense.
There's a pervading rape culture, men are bad.
The whole ball of wax.
20 years ago, a physicist submitted a
nonsense paper to the journal “Social Text”,
saying gravity just a “social construct”.
That embarrassed the journal,
But Social Text is still going strong,
and at universities, nothing really changed.
The best I can tap into is that this is kind of like a
religious architecture in their mind where privilege is sin.
So you can come up with these really nasty arguments
like to put white kids and chains in the floor.
It's an educational opportunity.
And if you frame it in terms of overcoming privilege
then it ... right in.
And anyone who dares criticize that
must be a conservative hack,
holding the same ideological position
as the Trump administration’s  attack on trans rights.
Maybe you are just conservative hacks
looking to defend white, your white privilege.
I don’t think so.
I’ve never voted for a republican in my life.
Nor have I
Actually none of the hoaxers is conservative.
My collaborators and I are left-wing academics
who can now say with confidence
these people don't speak for us.
The scholarship in these disciplines is utterly corrupted.
They have placed an agenda before the truth.
After this interview,
the editor of one of the hoaxed journals
did agree to talk to me.
Maybe you shouldn't be doing what you're doing
because it's gibberish, and they've proved it.
Yeah, yeah they didn’t prove, that's the problem.
That video will be available soon.